so our reaction is ready now all we need
again is a little bit of water just to
start it off so here today and we've
come back after hours because we need to
use this room for a long period of time
because we're going to do something
quite exciting because I'm Brady's
brought another camera which you can see
set up over there and we're going to use
that second camera to capture one second
of film every minute for maybe two or
three hours and we're getting some
time-lapse something I've seen on TV
with like flowers opening or plants
growing but never with chemistry
developing silver is one of the few
metallic elements that occurs naturally
as the metal in nature so that if you're
lucky you can wander around and find
lumps of silver lying around on the
ground and this is how in ancient times
silver was discovered so it has been
known for thousands if not tens of
thousands of years
Gold is somewhat similar and also copper
and but most of the metals combine too
easily with oxygen or other elements so
you don't find them naturally so I
thought what we do today it's through a
competition reaction and that
competition reaction is based on
something called the reactivity series
of metals so we're going to compare the
reactivity of two metals it's a bit like
a give a football we're going to give
one of those metals before ball and in
this case it's another component or
another salt component nitrate so the
two metals of the connect be competing
for the nitrate are silver and copper
and really these are related by
something called the reactivity series
one of these metals is going to win I
know that and I hope we'll find it
during this video silver had the
particular use in photography and in the
old days when people use photographic
film the black color that you saw on
developed negatives was is in fact
silver a photographic film consists of a
layer of silver bromide or sometimes
silver iodide and when the light shines
on
it the light just starts a tiny amount
of reaction making silver and then when
you put it in the developing solution
the catalytic amount of silver that
you've produced causes a big reaction
and you make a large amount of silver
and so you get this black color which
then you can print as pictures so on the
bench I've got a small beaker or an
Erlenmeyer flask that's weaker cause we
chemists call it which is full of
deionized water so we've passed the
water through a machine which has taken
out all of the other ions so that they
can't sort of play around with the
competition reaction that we want to
start today firstly I'm going to start
off by giving the prize of the
competition to silver so here I've got a
sample of silver nitrate it's sensitive
to light so I can't leave it out in the
bench very often so now what I want to
do is I'm going to put some into the
water to make a silver nitrate solution
so I want to make sure there's plenty in
there so that it's saturated now we're
going to put in the competitor so what
we're going to do is you're going to
take some copper copper metal and this
is just a sample of wire which I've
rubbed with some wire wall just to make
it sort of nice and shiny and now all
I'm going to do is dangle it into the
silver nitrate then it's going to start
to compete for the nitrate and we'll see
what happens so Brady started the
recording and I'm I think the best thing
for us to do is to go away and do
something a little bit more exciting and
come back and have a look in an hour
silver has become quite popular recently
as a potential new way of making things
a antibacterial killing bacteria so now
we're going to make some flash powder
and the flash powder that we're going to
make today is it's just two component
mixture it's very finely ground
magnesium and the second component is
its ground silver nitrate solid okay so
we take these two components and we mix
the two together very intimately and
Neal's just way in the materials out
right now
so we're going to put the magnesium and
the silver nitrate - two pairs together
into a small plastic container here
we're going to mix them very very
carefully and then we're going to see
what happens when we sort of initiate a
chemical reaction for hundreds of years
people have used silver spoons partly I
think because silver is quite easy to
make but also because the silver does
have properties that kill bacteria so a
silver spoon is that less likely to get
a harmful bacteria on it than if you
have one that's made out of wood or horn
of a cow or something like that so we're
mixing these very carefully in the fume
hood just in case the chemistry starts
before we want it to and in recent times
people have started making very very
fine particles of silver so-called
nanoparticles which can exist in
solutions so here I've got a solution of
silver nanoparticles you can see it
doesn't look silver it looks a bit
yellow actually and you can tell that
it's got particles in it because if I
can find a torch so here we've got
particles and you can see the particles
better if we shine light through it and
if you look at the light you can see
that there is a cone of light that looks
rather like the headlights of a car in
fog and this is an effect that is called
the Tyndall cone which indicates that
they're very very tiny particles
suspended in the solution so this is not
solute silver dissolved in the water but
that actually very tiny particles so
let's start the reaction just with a
little bit of water
Wow I think we should do it again though
yeah people are now using these silver
nanoparticles for all sorts of purposes
here you can see that they've been put
onto some sort of plastic and you can
now buy socks which have silver
nanoparticles on them which are claimed
to kill the bacteria that make your feet
smell so we're going to repeat the
reaction about the Bible one that's
going to come out somewhere in a silver
will conduct electricity it will also
conduct heat if you've ever tried
stirring tea with a silver spoon it gets
very hot you'll tend to drop it it also
conducts electricity well so we're going
to repeat the reaction so that you can
see it again because that was really
fast this time we're going to do it on a
glass dish so you can see it a bit
better well pour out a small amount so
our reaction is ready you know all we
need again is that little bit of water
just to start it off
I managed to close my eyes this time
during the Second World War when the US
government was involved in enriching
uranium as part of the Manhattan Project
they needed an enormous amount of wire
to make magnets and so a huge amount of
silver was taken from the US Treasury
where it was stored as silver to give
value to the US dollar and was turned
into wires to make magnets and I believe
that the silver was never returned at
least it wasn't returned at the end of
the war as was promised well have
managed to film maybe one minutes worth
of time by now maybe two because we've
been away about two hours so we're going
to go back and have a look at the flask
see if there's any changes if you
remember when we left it was a nice
clear solution a silver nitrate with
some copper wire which is just immersed
in site and it's going to look there's
been big changes in our flasks so if you
look carefully you can see now that the
copper wire itself is covered in very
very sharp crystals of silver which have
basically become deposited on the
surface copper has now won this chemical
reaction it's now going into solution
it's taking the salt element and
precipitating solid silver crystals so
if you look carefully you can see that
the color of the solution is changed
it was colorless now it's blue which
tells me that there's another iron
copper in solution